how about uh sliced alone sylvester
sloan rocky
rocky's story is this even right but
slices too sly's a good friend of mine
and when i first met him years ago he's
listening to my tapes and stuff invited
me over for dinner we started talking
and i said you know i've heard your
story from other people but i really
love to hear from the horse's mouth i
don't know how much is mythology you
know urban myth and how much is true
so he told me this whole story he said
the essence of it though was he said
he knew his whole life what he wanted to
do since he was very very young he
wanted to be
in the movie business period i mean not
just tv movies
and he just he said why was for him it
was a chance to have people not only
escape
but to inspire people and by the way
that drive is what made most of his
movies inspire people what they're
capable of to overcome unbelievable
obstacles because in his own life he
felt like he did that
when he was born he was pulled out by
the forceps that's why he looked the way
he did that's why he talked the way he
did
and he said so i really want to do that
and he said i knew why i want to do it i
wasn't willing to settle for anything
else
and he said what happened was i went out
to try and get jobs and it's not like i
went hurdry and they went you you're a
star it didn't work out real well
they looked at me and said hey you're
stupid looking do something else
you know
[Music]
there's no place for you in that stuff
you're never going to be a star in the
movies you're insane no one's going to
want to listen to somebody looks dopey
and talks out of the side of their mouth
right and you got no after no
after no after no he said i was thrown
out more fit more than 1500 times of
agents offices in new york i said there
aren't 1500 agents in new york i said i
know i've been home five six seven eight
nine times
he said remember one guy went in there
and i got in there at four o'clock
and he wouldn't see me so i stayed there
and i would not leave and i stayed
overnight he came back the next morning
i'm still sitting there
that's why i got my first job the guy
said fine come in here
and he sat down and he went through this
and he gave my first movie i said oh
really i thought rocky's first move he
said now this other movie i've never
heard of it
he said i said well what character you
play so i was in it for about 20 seconds
i was a thug and somebody beat up he
said because they made me feel like you
know
somebody people hate your guts you
getting beat up it'll be a good thing
and he did like three movies like that
never got anything kept going out and
rejection rejection rejection
so finally he realized it wasn't working
so he changed his approach
he said i was starving by the way he
said i couldn't pay for even to have
heat in my apartment
my wife was screaming at me every day to
go get a job i said well why didn't you
he said because i knew that if i got a
job he said i'd get seduced back and i'd
lose my hunger
he said i knew that the only way i could
do this is if it was the only choice if
i burned all of the bridges
because if i did a normal job pretty
soon i'd be caught up in that rhythm and
that stuff and i feel okay about my life
and i feel like my dream would just
gradually disappear
he said i wanted to keep that hunger
that hunger was the only thing i thought
was my advantage
he said my wife didn't understand that
at all he said we'd have these vicious
fights and he said it was freezing
so i was broke we had no money and he
said so i finally went to the public
library one day because it was warm so i
didn't want to read anything
since i went in new york public library
so i was hanging out there and i sat
down on this chair
and somebody left a book there and he
said
i looked at this book i know the poems
of edgar allan's stories of edgar allan
poe
and he said so i started reading and he
said i got totally in the edgar allan
poe he said i know everything about it
he goes on for another 20 minutes
telling me about edgar allan poe he
knows everything how he died what it was
about what really happened
and i said well what did poe do for you
he said poe got me out of myself
he got me to think about how i could
touch other people and not worry about
myself so much
and he said it made me decide to become
a writer i said just imagine rocky the
writer right
and he said so i tried to write a bunch
of screenplays nothing worked nothing to
work i was totally broke
he said i didn't even have 50 bucks and
he said finally he said i sold a script
it was called paradise alleys it's a
movie i made many years later but i sold
it
and he said i sold it for a hundred
bucks he said but a hundred bucks was a
ton of money man i was so thrilled i
thought i'm on my way
but it never led to anything and he said
so finally he said i kept going and
going going he said finally we were so
broke
he said i hocked my wife's jewelry he
said tony there's some things in life
you should never do
he said that was basically the end of
our relationship she hated my gut so
much
he said now we were so broke we had
nothing no food no money
and he said the one thing i loved most
in the world was my dog
he said i love my dog because he gave me
unconditional love unlike my wife
and he said so what happened was though
we were so broke that to survive
i couldn't even feed my dog so i went to
a liquor store so it was the lowest day
of my life
and i stood outside the liquor store
trying to sell my dog to strangers
he said i tried to sell my dog for 50
bucks and he said there's finally this
one guy negotiated with me and bought my
dog for me my best friend on earth for
25
he said i walked away from there and i
cried this was the worst thing that ever
happened in my life
he said two weeks later i'm watching a
fight between muhammad ali
and wepner this white guy that's getting
bludgeoned but just keeps on coming
and he said i got an idea he said i as
soon as the fight ended i started
writing he said i wrote for 20 straight
hours i did not sleep
i wrote the entire movie in 20 hours
straight right then
saw the fight wrote the movie whole
thing done he said i was shaking at the
end i was so excited he said i really
knew man i knew what i wanted
i knew why i wanted it he said just like
you teach that formula he said but i
said man i took the action now it's time
to deliver
and so he said i went out and started
trying to sell it to agents and they all
would read it and they'd say you know
this is predictable this is stupid this
is sappy
he said i wrote down all the things they
said and i read them the night of the
oscars when we won
and it was really good right
the greatest revenge is massive success
and he said so what happened was he said
i kept going trying to sell it trying to
sell it nobody go and i'm broke i'm
starving
he said finally i meet these guys they
read it and they believe in the script
and they love it
and they offer me a hundred and
twenty-five thousand dollars for my
script
i said oh my god you must have been out
of your mind he said i was
i said just one thing though guys you
got a deal based on one thing they said
what's that he said
i got a star in it they went what are
you talking about you're a writer so no
no i'm an actor
because no no you're a writer so no no
i'm an actor
that is my story and i'm rocky he said i
got to play it you know i got to be the
head person i got to be the starring
role
there's no way we're not gonna pay 125
000 take some no name and stick you in
that throw our money away
we need a star you know and they want to
have ryan o'neal play rocky to give you
a picture
can you imagine that's who they picked
right and so he said no way ryan o'neal
isn't rocky i'm rock he went through
this whole thing right
they finally he said they said well take
it or leave it he said i left the room i
said
if that's what you believe you don't get
my script any left here's a man with no
money
none totally broke offered 125 000
more money seen his lifetime and he
walked away because he knew his real
what
knew his real what and why he wanted he
was committed to it
so he said they called him a few weeks
later and they came and brought him back
and they offered him a quarter of a
million dollars
not the star in his own movie
he turned it down 250 000 they came back
their final offers 325
000 they wanted this thing he said not
without me and they said no
they finally compromised and they gave
him 35 000
and points in the movie because they
said if this is going to happen then
you're going to take the risk with us
and the bottom line is we don't think it
will work but at least we won't spend a
bunch of money on you
and then they only spent a million
dollars to make rocky and it grows 200
million dollars at the time
i mean it was done pretty well but
what's interesting about this is
here's i said what'd you do i mean even
35 000 it's not a quarter of a million
that's a lot of money when you don't
have 25 bucks i said what's the first
thing you did i figured you went out and
partied or something he said
i went to that liquor store for three
straight days and hoped that the man who
had my dog
frequented the store just because i want
to buy back my dog
i thought that was so cool right
that was really cool i said what
happened he said third day i was there
this guy
walks by and i see him and i can't
believe it and there's my dog
and i looked at him i said sir remember
me and he said it's been about a month
and a half
by the time this would all come about he
said remember me you know i'm the guy i
just told you the dog he goes yeah yeah
i love the dog he said look
he said i was so broke i was starving
he's my best friend i'm sure you love
him too
but i gotta have him black please i beg
of you he said i'll pay you a hundred
dollars to the dog i know you paid me 25
i'll give you 100. the man said
absolutely not no way he's my dog now
you can't buy him back
right and sly said you know tony you
know you say know your outcome i said
yeah he said i knew it and he said i
kept changing my approach so i went
500 for the dog the guy said absolutely
no way
he said a thousand dollars for my dog
the guy said no amount of money in the
north is ever gonna get this dog from
you
i said what'd you do he said i knew my
outcome right because he listened his
tape skipped to him he says i
take massive action he said i got my dog
i just kept changing my approach so i
got it i said what it cost you
15 000 and a part
in rocky the guys in rocky
you know that dog in rocky butt kiss
that sly's real dog
right that's the dog he bought him back
so so he put his dog in the movie and he
put the guy in the movie and paid 15
grand well he had 35 000. and that's
pretty cool pretty awesome
so there's always a way if you're
committed
just gotta keep changing your approach